okay this is pete peppers and this is um
a tutorial video on the
fifth and final
level type for now which is the honey
levels
they're introduced into the game in
level 76
and they work a little bit differently
than the other level types so we'll just
talk about
how they work
alright so it tells us we have to eat
the honey and save the bears
so
you can see that there's honey squares
that are similar to ice
in a lot of ways and
when we make matches next to the bears
that are trapped in honey
they are set free so you can see on this
level we need to collect
30 of them
and these bears these honey bears here
are
already at the um
they're already ready to be released so
they come out with just one match
but as you progress um
there'll be other ones that are buried
deeper inside the
honey as well
it's pretty straightforward
um they work like i said very similar in
a similar way to how
find the bears levels work except for
with those you have to clear off the
tiles
by making matches on top of them and in
honey levels you just have to
use that to make matches next to them so
they're sort of like raised tiles
and um
they work a little bit differently
so that's a simple one let's look at one
more
real quick
to show how they can be um
trapped
in much more difficult
situations
find one real quick here
okay so these bears you can see they're
a little bit more obscured and they're
sort of
off the screen
this is a this is a double layered
hunting square right here so this would
take two
two matches to
break free
you can see the candy moves around in a
circular
motion in order to get to these ones
we're going to have to make fish or
striped candies
so you can see that this gets a lot more
difficult
fairly quickly
so you can see i hit that bear once and
now it it's raised up to the surface and
it will it'll be free next time
it gets hit
it's interesting on these levels where
the um
where the tiles go in different
directions or the candies moving
different directions i should say
it's
it seems simple enough that you know the
um
that you would be able to follow it but
since
at least for me that since we've been
playing match three games where
everything comes down all the time you
really have to take a second to think
about how
um
the pieces are gonna move
so you can see we got that one out by
hitting it twice
the fish
hit them once and it brings it up to the
surface
and
a little bit later we'll get into
levels that have even thicker layers
and we'll just look at one of those real
quick
i know that level
140 is
that's one of the hardest levels in the
game right now i know it has
been really thick
okay so here you can see the honey has
kind of the honeycomb pattern on it
so like on the first board
on this one the bear we need is right
here
and it's
this will take three pits to free
because it's not the thickest
and maybe this one yeah it'll be three
this would be four and this would be
actually five that's the thickest
we actually got a really bad start on
this where i can't make matches on that
side at all so
luckily i'm not trying to play the level
to completion i'm just trying to show
you
how many different layers of light
sports or honey work so
you see that honey sometimes a little um
so that was one hit two hits and then
the fish gives you the third hit
sometimes honey will conceal
special candies and things like that
that you'll find as you break it down
so honey levels um like i said they're
the last ones that were
introduced into the game
i wouldn't say they're the hardest but
some of those levels are really hard
um
when you look at it you just tell like i
said um
these ones
or it would take two hits
this will take three hits
and there are only four hit ones on here
but this one will take five hits so
depending on how thick the the um
the honey is
it tells you how many hits you have to
make to free that square up and when
you're looking for bears
if they're
on the thinner honey like this one the
two layer you'll be able to see the bear
just like in the ice when it's down to
one layer
but when it's in these thicker ones you
can't see it so you all a lot of times
you'll have to try to pay attention to
where you found the bears the first time
and go after them that way
so if you have any questions about honey
levels and how they work leave a comment
please like the video if you found it
helpful
and visit our site
candycrustsodasagatips.com to find out
everything about how this game works
thanks